impfen auch in praxen hausärzte sollen
nach ostern erste impfdosen bekommen
scharfe töne zwischen usa und china
bei einem treffen der supermächte kommt
es zum eklat
besondere auszeichnung für
impfstoffentwickler die beiden gründer
schein und therapie erhalten das große
verdienstkreuz mit stern
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
heute am freitag auch norbert lehmann
ist wieder an meiner seite in einen
schönen guten abend von mir noch zwei
wochen bis ostern doch noch ist völlig
unklar wo wie und mit wem wir die tage
verbringen können während die einen
immer noch hoffen dass restaurants und
hotels öffnen
stimmen die anderen politik und medizin
auf eine rückkehr zu wieder strengeren
corona maßnahmen ein
deutschland ist drin in der dritten
welle heißt es kurz vor der neuen bund
länder runde am montag an seinem stern
fasst die situation zusammen
ein frühling mit mehr freiheit mehr
normalität der wunsch bei so vielen
schon solange das land aber fährt ganz
offenbar in eine ganz andere richtung
hamburg zum beispiel zieht heute die
sogenannte notbremse nimmt ab morgen
öffnungs schritte wieder zurück die
virus zahlen werden schlechter nicht nur
hier nicht nur ein bisschen sondern
schnell
wir befinden uns in der dritten welle
der pandemie die zahlen steigen der
anteil der mutationen ist groß es liegen
also noch ziemlich herausfordernde
wochen vor uns herausfordernde wochen es
klingt fast alles wie vor weihnachten
leider hat sich die zunahme der
fallzahlen in den letzten tagen
beschleunigt er ist nun ganz deutlich
exponentiell die inzidenz steigt in den
altersgruppen unter 60 jahren deutlich
an am meisten bei den 15 bis 49 jährigen
die sogenannte sieben tage inzidenz
wieder mit tempo unterwegs richtung 100
heute ein sprung auf 95,6 mehr als
17.000 neue infektionen innerhalb eines
tages etwa 4600 mehr als vor einer woche
deutlich gesunken war zuletzt die zahl
der täglichen covi todesfälle wohl vor
allem weil viele sehr alte menschen den
impfschutz haben und auch die wichtige
zahl der korona intensivpatienten hatte
sich massiv verringert doch auch hier
wieder schlechte aussichten
es ist sehr gut möglich dass wir um
ostern eine ähnliche lage haben wie vor
weihnachten mit sehr hohen fallzahlen
sehr vielen schweren verläufen vielen
todesfällen und krankenhäuser die stark
belastet sind und ich bitte sie auch
verzichten sie auf reisen im in und
ausland wieder appelle und wieder die
frage was tun für karl lauterbach heute
auch dabei in berlin ist die antwort
klar man kann es drehen und wenden wie
man will wir müssen zurück in den job
zurück in den virus stillstand eine
forderung vor der nächsten bund länder
krisenkonferenz am montag neuer streit
ist absehbar
sicher scheint nur der frühling mit viel
mehr freiheit ist nicht in sicht
da müssen wir uns wohl noch bis zu dem
zeitpunkt gedulden wenn die mehrheit der
menschen hier im land geimpft sein wird
am nachmittag gab es dazu den impf
gipfel im kanzleramt mit den chefinnen
und chefs der länder
sie berieten darüber wie man das impfen
beschleunigen könnte auch mit hilfe der
hausärzte und ärztinnen andrea maurer
vor wenigen minuten tritt die kanzlerin
vor die presse mit dieser botschaft
das ziel unserer heutigen beratung war
klar wir wollen und aber april können
wir das auch schneller und flexibler
werden
wir wollen dass auch hier die
sprichwörtliche und im übrigen auch
bewährte deutsche gründlichkeit um mehr
deutsche flexibilität ergänzt wird
am ziel bis zum sommer allen bürgerinnen
und bürgern ein impfangebot zu machen
hält die kanzlerin fest
im beschluss zum impfgipfel ist von
zusätzlich 4 millionen bei montech dosen
an die eu die rede von denen 580.000
dosen auf deutschland entfallen diese
sollen insbesondere für hot spots und
zur abwehr von virus mutanten eingesetzt
werden heißt es
auch die hausärzte sollen nun
großflächig in die impfungen einbezogen
werden nach ostern soll es losgehen
der gesundheitsminister war schon am
morgen vor zu großen erwartungen
mit den mengen die wir in den ersten
aprilwochen das wird sich im mai stand
heute schon ändern können aber den
ersten aprilwochen erwarten wird es
beginnen können inhouse in arztpraxen
haushalts praxen erstmal mit etwa
umgerechnet eine sprechstunde pro woche
diese an einem tag in der woche würde in
einer hausarztpraxis geimpft
mehrere ministerpräsidenten haben sich
beim impfgipfel auch für den russischen
impfstoff sputnik wie stark gemacht der
befindet sich im zulassungsverfahren ist
aber noch nicht bestellt die datenlage
müsse geklärt werden sagt sparen genauso
mengen und verfügbarkeiten wenn über
diese fragen klarheit es lassen sich auf
verträge schließen und ich bin
tatsächlich sehr dafür wenn die
europäische union jetzt nicht da auch
was macht dass wir es dann national
machen
in deutschland wird unterdessen seit
heute wieder mit astrazeneca geimpft in
stuttgart am vormittag auch dieser
72-jährige mann winfried kretschmann
ministerpräsident von baden württemberg
es war sein regulärer impftermin die
botschaft dieser bilder ist auch eine
politische die impfkampagne läuft wieder
der frage an chacón dollar banerjee in
berlin
welches signal geht er nun von diesem
impfgipfel aus vor allem das
viel aber nicht alles daran gesetzt wird
jetzt das impf tempo zu steigern wenn
ich mal zusammenfassen was die kanzlerin
gerade noch zusätzlich in der
pressekonferenz gesagt hat die gerade in
dem moment hier zu ende gegangen ist
wir haben ja schon gehört die hausärzte
werden zwei wochen früher eingebunden
als eigentlich geplant bei der bei der
priorisierung will man flexibler
vorgehen wobei noch nicht ganz klar ist
was das bedeutet aber hausärzte sollen
da wohl ein bisschen mehr spielraum
bekommen und es soll vor allem auch
weniger bürokratie geben für die
hausärzte bei den impfungen aber das
haben wir auch schon gehört es wird
nicht richtig viel tempo am anfang geben
weil eben der impfstoff weiterhin knapp
bleibt 20 impfdosen für jeweils für
50.000 praxen in deutschland weit das
geht in die breite aber noch nicht so
richtig in die menge und jens spahn hat
haben wir auch gerade gehört hat ja den
alleingang bei sputnik wie gefordert hat
die kanzlerin gerade auf nachfrage in
der pressekonferenz noch einmal gesagt
sie sei dafür wenn impfstoffe zu nutzen
die von der eu zugelassen worden sind
und setzte sie setzen nicht auf
alleingänge
es sei denn die eu wird sputnik wie
nicht zuzulassen das heißt also man muss
erst einmal abwarten was brüssel da
macht es wird mehr tempo geben aber wer
wirklich ungeduldig ist wird damit noch
nicht ganz zufrieden sein
vielen dank für die einordnung
intel-manager die ergebnisse vom
impfgipfel bereiten wir auch in unserer
zdf heute app für sie auf dazu einen
überblick was konkret passieren muss
damit die impfkampagne ins rollen kommt
und wann wir das virus so in den griff
bekommen könnten
korruptionsvorwürfe vetternwirtschaft
lobbyismus die staatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt es sind turbulente wochen für
cdu und csu
und jetzt der nächste fall der
csu-bundestagsabgeordnete tobias zech
hat sein bundestagsmandat und alle
parteiämter niedergelegt hintergrund
sind vorwürfe ich habe sein mandat mit
beratungstätigkeiten für eine partei in
nord mazedonien verquickt
in diesem fall geht es nicht um
geschäfte in der korona krise in sechs
monaten ist bundestagswahl die grünen in
umfragen auf platz 2 treten mit dem
anspruch an das kanzleramt zu erobern
heute haben sie ihren entwurf für ein
wahlprogramm vorgelegt und sprechen von
einer vitaminspritze für das land
messlatte der politik soll der
klimaschutz sein
patricia wiedemeier über das grüne
programm frisch modern engagiert so
sehen sie sich so präsentieren sie sich
die grüne parteispitze will mit ihrem
programm die republik komplett umbauen
deutschland wirbt saturiert müde
wandlungs unlustig ja mittelmäßig wir
legen mit diesem bundestagswahlprogramm
vitamine vor eine vitaminspritze für
dieses land
136 seiten voller vitamine auf eine
sozial ökologische marktwirtschaft
setzen die grünen oberstes ziel dabei
ist immer der klimaschutz die co2
emissionen sollen bis 20.30 um 70
prozent reduziert werden
ab 20.30 nur noch emissionsfreie autos
neu zugelassen erneuerbare energien
stärker ausgebaut werden der
kohleausstieg vollendet sein
wir bringen mit unserem programm
deutschland endlich auf den 1,5 grad
fahrt das schaffen wir nur alle zusammen
als gemeinschaft insgesamt denn
klimaschutz ist keine zukunftsaufgabe
klimaschutz ist jetzt ein
investitionsprogramm von 50 milliarden
pro jahr soll aufgelegt werden unter
anderem für digitalisierung und den
klimafreundlichen umbau der industrie
und der infrastruktur finanziert werden
soll das mit höheren steuern bei 100000
euro einkommen pro person oder 200.000
europa steigt der steuersatz leicht auf
45 prozent ab 250 tausend auf 48 und ab
einem vermögen von 2 millionen kommen 1
prozent steuern hinzu
zudem wollen die grünen mehr kredite
aufnehmen die schuldenbremse soll dafür
gelockert werden geplant auch ein
bundesweiter mieten deckel und eine
kindergrundsicherung 136 seiten die die
republik von heute deutlich
verändern würden wieder geht die türkei
massiv gegen oppositionelle vor
dutzende vertreter der prokurdischen
partei hdp sind bei razzien festgenommen
worden darunter mehrere hochrangige
funktionäre
die gründe sind unklar am mittwoch hatte
die generalstaatsanwaltschaft ein verbot
der hdp beantragt ihr vorwurf
verbindungen zur verbotenen pkk
beobachter vermuten dass präsident
erdogan mit blick auf die nächsten
wahlen die opposition schwächen möchte
was von der neuen us regierung in den
letzten tagen in puncto außenpolitik zu
hören ist lässt aufhorchen
erst attackierte präsident biden den
russischen präsidenten putin nun
rumpelte es zwischen us-außenminister
blinken und dem chinesischen top
diplomaten bei einem treffen in alaska
schlugen beide scharfe töne an
wenn der mann daniel die
tiefsttemperatur heute in anchorage
minus 19 grad
so in etwa muss es sich auch hier
drinnen angefühlt haben beim ersten
offiziellen dialog des us außenministers
mit seinem chinesischen gesprächspartner
wir müssen unter anderem über unsere
großen sorgen wegen chinas haltung
sprechen wenn es zum beispiel um die
uiguren in china und hongkong taiwan um
die cyber-attacken gegen die usa oder
die wirtschaftlichen zwänge unserer
verbündeten
jede dieser aktionen bedroht die globale
stabilität
die usa müssen doch selbst an ihrem
image in der welt arbeiten und aufhören
ihre demokratie form in den rest der
welt tragen zu wollen
viele amerikaner haben wenig vertrauen
in das system der usa offene
konfrontation auf großer bühne am abend
so heißt es habe es dann doch noch
substanziellere gespräche gegeben
diese seien dann zumindest etwas ruhiger
und diplomatische verlaufen
während die geopolitische rolle der usa
in den letzten jahren schwächer geworden
ist hat china an stärke hinzugewonnen
die gespräche in anchorage haben
deutlich gemacht dass peking seine
starke stellung in der welt unter keinen
umständen wieder einbüßen möchte
und auch die usa haben ihre sicht der
dinge in einem für viele überraschend
scharfen ton klar gemacht in diesem
moment geht die letzte gesprächsrunde zu
ende
joe biden äußerte sich zum thema heute
kurz und knapp er sei stolz auf seinen
außenminister wer nach der jump'n'run
nun eine erste annäherung zwischen china
und den usa erwartet hatte wurde vorerst
enttäuscht
der erste corona impfstoff ist ja
bekanntlich eine hauptsächlich deutsche
entwicklungsarbeit der firma biotec das
mainzer forscher ehepaar uhr sahin und
slam tour de ski ist dafür jetzt
besonders geehrt worden mit dem großen
bundesverdienstkreuz mit stern
bundespräsident steinmeier betonte die
weitsicht der beiden mediziner in der
frühen phase der pandemie helfe nun auf
der ganzen welt leben zu retten ein
porträt von bombenserie die höchste
ehrung deutschlands für verdienste um
das gemeinwohl in diesem fall das
gemeinwohl der ganzen welt im beisein
von kanzlerin merkel erhalten die
impfstoffentwicklers lektüre chi und qi
sahin das bundesverdienstkreuz
ihre bahnbrechende entdeckung rettet
menschenleben sie rettet existenzen
sie sichert unser gesellschaftliches
wirtschaftliches und kulturelles
überleben seit jahren forscht das
ehepaar zürich sahin im bereich
krebsmedizin
als die beiden im januar 2020 von dem
neuartigen corona virus in johann lesen
sehen sie die gefahr für die ganze welt
und richten die arbeit ihrer firma
biotec neu aus wir wussten dass wir eine
technologie haben eine impfstoff
technologie haben die uns ermöglichen
könnte ein impfstoff wird sich in kurzer
zeit zu machen und dementsprechend haben
wir das haben wir die verantwortung
geführt dass wir etwas tun müssen sie
die wissenschaftliche direktorin er der
vorstandsvorsitzende
in weniger als einem jahr entwickelt bei
montech den ersten marktreifen m rna
impfstoff überhaupt viel spreche dafür
dass die impfung auch die virus
weitergabe verhindert so die forscher
doch die arbeit sei noch lange nicht
erledigt
in der regel erfolgen auszeichnungen
wenn die zielgerade erreicht ist und die
anstrengung vorbei ist hier allerdings
ist die aufgabe erst gelöst wenn jeder
den impfstoff auch erhalten kann und
geschützt ist daneben wollen sie
weiterhin die krebsforschung
revolutionieren und neue behandlungen
bei autoimmunerkrankungen entwickeln
türe chi und sahin haben noch viel vor
jetzt blicken wir auf ein besonderes
stück deutscher geschichte das im januar
1990 angefangen hat mit dem sturm auf
die stasi-zentrale in ost berlin das
plötzliche ende der ddr staatssicherheit
bedeutete die rettung unzählige akten
seit fast 30 jahren können deshalb
betroffene und behörden nachlesen wer
wen bespitzelt hat 7,4 millionen mal
wurde das bislang genutzt
heute stellte der bundesbeauftragte für
die stasi-unterlagen seinen letzten
bericht vor
cornelia schiemenz licht ins dunkel
bringen tägliche arbeit der
stasi-unterlagen-behörde wie hier in der
außenstelle dresden lagern überall noch
immer dutzende zerrissene akten
sie wollen zusammen gepuzzelt gelesen
historisch bewertet werden
auch wenn die behörde im sommer formell
aufgelöst und organisatorisch ins
bundesarchiv überführt wird
jeder bürger hat weiterhin die
möglichkeiten antrag bei uns zu stellen
auch jeder forscher kann weiterhin
antrag stellen die akteneinsicht findet
hier vor ort auch weiterhin statt so
dass sich für den bürger nichts ändert
ende 1990 nahm die stasi unterlagen
behörde ihre arbeit auf zum kernstück
wurden millionen akten mit teilweise
dramatischen schicksalen joachim gauck
marianne birthler und roland jahren
gaben der behörde stimme und gesicht mit
der überführung ins bundesarchiv wird
auch das amt des bundesbeauftragten
aufgelöst
meine erkenntnis ist die stasi
unterlagen können unsere heutigen
gesellschaft einen großen dienst
erweisen
es geht nicht nur um vergangenheit im
stasi unterlagen archiv steckt enorm
viel stoff für die gestaltung von
demokratie der dresdner künstler michael
freudenberg für die stasi ein
gefährliches subjekt 52 ems verwandte
wohnung der komplette briefverkehr
abgefangen all das hat er auch seiner
1000 seitige nackte erfahren
die verdeckten dinge war etwas klarer
ja und die vermutungen konnten aufgelöst
werden und da hat man nur die
möglichkeit gehabt so zu sagen den
leuten jetzt innerlich zu verteilen
verzeihen aufarbeiten bewahren das wird
und muss weiter gehen auch unter dem
dach des bundesarchivs for future ist
nach wochen der pause wieder da um auf
den klimawandel aufmerksam zu machen mit
weltweiten protesten wegen corona
dezentral in vielen einzelnen aktionen
auch in mehr als 200 deutschen städten
in berlin etwa malten die aktivisten auf
eine brücke den schriftzug eine andere
welt ist möglich
groß auch die botschaft in hamburg wir
alle für 1,5 grad ist da auf 60 metern
länge zu lesen und in münchen fordern
sie auf einem riesigen transparent keine
leeren versprechen mehr tja und nun zum
sport und zur auslosung der
champions-league-viertelfinals arbeit
und da kommt es ganz dicke für den bvb
manchester city heißt der gegner der
englische tabellenführer mit trainer pep
guardiola ist momentan wohl das beste
team europas und der titelverteidiger
münchen der trifft auf den finalgegner
des vorjahrs paris st-germain hansi
flick muss den henkelpott gegen die star
truppe um mvp und nehmer verteidigen die
bayern haben zunächst heimrecht können
zuhause vorlegen natürlich ist ein
schwerer gegner das haben wir im finale
schon gezeigt oder gesehen
trotzdem ist auch für uns der sache wir
haben auch enorme qualität edin terzic
trifft mit seinem bvb auf pep guardiola
der männer
die endlich den europäischen titel
bescheren will außerdem empfängt porto
chelsea london und madrid liverpool mit
jürgen klopp schon 2019 champions league
sieger und thomas tuchel dem neuen beim
fc chelsea werden gleich vier teams von
deutschen trainern geführt
bundestrainer joachim löw hat den kader
für die wm qualifikationsspiele gegen
island rumänien und nord mazedonien
bekannt gegeben neben den england
legionären und ilkay gündogan sind auch
neue gesichter im team der 18 jährige
jamal muss ja von bayern münchen und der
ein jahr jüngere florian würz von bayer
leverkusen nach fast fünf monaten dürfen
morgen wieder fans ein profi fußball
spiel besuchen
bei der drittliga begegnung hansa
rostock gegen den halleschen fc haben
die behörden 777 zuschauer erlaubt wegen
der sehr niedrigen incidents zahl den
rostock nur heimische
dauerkartenbesitzer dürfen kommen vor
dem stadion sind corona schnelltests
vorgeschrieben zum auftakt des biathlon
weltcup final in östersund gab es für
die deutschen sprinterinnen und sprinter
nur eine einzige top-ten-platzierung
nämlich für roman rees als zehnter
erfolgreich dagegen das alpine dsv
quartett in lenzerheide
beim weltcup finale erreichten lena dürr
andrea filser linus straße und alexander
schmid im team-event rang zwei hinter
norwegen und vor österreich und
besonders überzeugend andrea filser die
alle teamduelle das was von mir
dank genau weiß ob das ganze wochenende
so kalt bleibt und ob uns noch mehr
schnee erwartet das sagte uns gleich
katja horneffer so viel von uns danke
für ihr interesse
claus kleber erwartet sie heute um 22
uhr zum heute journal
und wir sind morgen abend wieder da
punkt 7 und freuen uns wenn sie dabei
sind bis dahin
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
morgen bekommt unser dauerhoch margarete
unterstützung durch tief otto
das führt dazu dass es bei uns von
nordwesten allmählich etwas milder wird
und dass es morgen abend an der nordsee
auch etwas regnet davor aber ist es noch
sehr kalt ab mittelmeer gibt es unwetter
und heute nacht fällt am alpenrand noch
etwas schnee das sind doch noch
schneeschauer in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen dabei sonst ist es häufig
klar und deswegen wird das eisig kalt es
gibt strengen frost von minus acht bis
minus zehn grad in der lausitz im
erzgebirge im thüringer wald aber auch
am alpenrand und nach dieser eisigen
nacht da wird es dann auch tagsüber
nicht besonders mild ja in sachsen und
den bayern da bleibt sogar dauerfrost
von minus drei bis null grad vom rhein
main gebiet über den niederrhein bis zur
nordsee geht es immerhin so auf 67 grad
rauf und an den alpen kann es auch
morgen über tag noch etwas schneien
sonst wird das ein sehr freundlicher
sonnabend besonders westlich des rheins
und am oberrhein scheint die sonne
strahlt vom westen werden die wolken
dichter und bringen auch etwas regen mit
zunächst mal auf sylt oder auch auf
helgoland am sonntag ziehen diese
dichteren wolken weiter nach südosten
dann kann es in den mittelgebirgen auch
noch mal schneien
es wird windig bei null bis neun grad
und danach von tag zu tag etwas milder
schönen abend noch